tonight we have a date for the return of
some ccsd
students and teachers back to the
classroom eight news now reporter orco
manon joining us live to explain the
timeline
and how parents are reacting orco
well if your kitchen table looks like
this you are not alone because of
distance learning
we have turned our homes into makeshift
schools but there is some good news
in just 33 days some ccsc students
are heading back to the classroom it's
definitely a relief
the clark county school district
announcing pre-k through third grade
students will begin hybrid learning on
march 1st that includes some
in-person instruction syrah valenzuela
tells me her two daughters in first and
third grade have been struggling with
distance education during covet 19
because they can't be with their
classmates at least just to
talk and to laugh and to joke around i
think
it you know they're really looking
forward to that ccsd
sending this memo to educators saying
they can return to the classroom on
february 22nd to prepare
kindergarten teacher kristen nigro is
ready it's a lot different when you have
the person in front of you rather than
looking through a computer screen
and so i think that it's going to really
help them focus but what about
other students ccsd says quote
throughout the second semester
the district will work to transition
additional grade levels to the hybrid
instructional model but education
advocates are concerned there's no
timeline yet the kids that are
having the most challenges from a mental
health perspective
are older students but right now we have
no plan for when those kids are going to
go back
but many like valenzuela agree this is a
good first step
now at least there's a little bit more
of a peace of mind
the district is asking parents to fill
out this online questionnaire by the end
of the day friday to help plan
for the pre-k through grade three
transition and you can find a link to
that on our website
8newsnow.com reporting live tonight orco
mana 8 news now